millions and millions of pounds are
spent in attacking Islam and this is a
this is a fact where Muslims are known
for giving the humanitarian work and
charity the question is how much we
actually give when it comes to
protecting Islam but what was the
sisters what about the people who are on
the front line doing Dawa and trying to
give the clear understanding of Islam to
the people are we not gonna help these
people recent Pew Research shows that
between 2010 and 2016 160,000 people
have left Islam why because it's name is
wrong no because they have a
misunderstanding they have no one there
to clarify it for them now what are we
doing we have reached collectively 52
million you heard that right
million people weren't white and we're
reaching two to three million people on
a monthly basis you can be a part of
that people are taking the Shahada
people are coming back to Islam people
are practicing around the world and you
can be a part of that but we have one
big problem and we need your help if we
do not get the necessary funds that we
need we will not have a studio we want
to have a media team we won't have an
editing team and we cannot dedicate our
full time with our teachers to conveying
this message
and carrying it on now we need the
following two billion Muslims exists on
this planet we are looking for just 500
selected people that would give just a
hundred pounds and this will help us to
convey the message clearly around the
world if we don't ask you for help
brothers and sisters
[Music]
who will lend Allah a goodly loan so
Allah might multiply that low for him
multitudes some above and sisters you
heard that beautiful recitation from
brother Matt hijab only request for you
to do is go and click on the link below
and donate if you cannot do that at
least share this video it's a hundred
percent free to do so may Allah grant
every single one of you guys Jenna
assalamu alaikum what
by benefit